vous dégagez donnons pas de chapeau
contrairement à maria bodin yvette elle
est bien réelle avec ses frères camille
et rené ces trois agriculteurs de dolus
le sec sont devenus les héros du film
documentaire de silvestre chatenet qui
n'est autre que leurs voisins en passant
ici ça me rappelait est ce que je voyais
chez ma grand mère donc j'ai trouvé que
c'était une chance une opportunité de
pouvoir filmer c'est ce mode de vie qui
est un petit peu comme par le passé mais
qui est aussi plein de modernisme parce
qu'ici on travaille un tracteur moderne
etc le réalisateur a suivi au plus près
la vie de la ferme de la giraudière
entre 2005 et 2006 pour saisir le
quotidien de la famille trion en tout 50
heures d'image condenser en une heure
trente de films qui témoignent de
l'authenticité campagnarde bien loin de
la caricature des bodin's est encore
plus éloigné de l'agriculture moderne
c'est-à-dire pendant un an je suis venu
régulièrement voir ce qui se passait
et parfois il se passe rien
d'extraordinaire et pas soit il s'est
parfois il se passe des choses très
chouette comme la naissance d'un petit
chevreau il en fait il se passe toujours
quelque chose à la ferme après on
capture pas tout il faut faire un choix
quand je fais pas ma thèse de cinéma
non mais ça c'est la réalité
c'est bien fait quand même
dommage que bon c'est dommage que maman
soit plus là
on a mis dans le film on s'y attendait
pas c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens ça
les a marqués aussi des moments
d'émotion inscrits sur pellicule pour
yvette qui en un mois s'est retrouvé
propulsé icône du lochois à loches le
film a déjà enregistré 1700 entrées pour
à peine 7000 habitants
la vue est bien quelque chose pour
l'heure cette copie du film sont en
circulation de à paris les autres en
région centre à blois vendôme loges et
amboise à noter vous pouvez découvrir
yvette sur grand écran à tour jusqu'au
mardi 12 août au cinéma les studios